we now live in an era where to have a
successful career it's not only
necessary that you know about
programming languages but also actually
have to be good at them I'm around from
simply learn and these are the top five
programming languages that you should
consider learning in 2018 at number five
we have C sharp a C sharp developer
earns around eighty eight thousand US
dollars per year now let's talk about
some of the features of c-sharp c-sharp
rose to fame in the 2000s and as
Helzberg who's the founder of c shop
feels it's a lot more closer to c++ than
it is to java it was developed by
Microsoft and supports the concepts of
object-oriented programming it is one of
the most powerful programming languages
for the.net framework
he takes head of Visual C++ and is best
suited for applications on Windows
Android and iOS some of the companies
that use this technology are Accenture
enforces HP and Microsoft now let's talk
about some of the applications of sisha
it is used in the backend of several
popular websites like Bing Microsoft
Dell Visual Studio and market watch
number four Java a Java developer earns
around 102 thousand US dollars now let's
talk about some of its features Java is
a general-purpose programming language
and is one of the most popularly used
around the world it is most popular for
its feature write once run anywhere it's
a post object-oriented programming its
platform independent and provides high
cross functionality there are more than
three billion devices that are on Java
applications its Java frameworks like
spring struts and hibernate are also
very popular it has a huge community and
from it's a lot of support it is used in
web development app development stock
market and big data some of the
companies that use Java for the products
are Capital One Amazon LinkedIn Intel
and Netflix let's talk about some of the
applications of Java it is used in the
backend of several popular websites like
Google Amazon Twitter and YouTube it's
also extensively used in hundred
applications number three Swift no Swift
developer earns around hundred three
thousand US dollars per year now let's
talk about some of its features in March
2017 it made the top ten in the monthly
TOB Index ranking of popular programming
languages it was developed by Apple in
2014 for iOS Linux and Mac app
development it is open source it's easy
to learn just like Python supports
almost everything from objective-c this
less coding required and can be used
with IBM surf sandbox and IBM bluemix
some of the companies that use swift are
IBM LinkedIn uber lyft and Coursera now
let's talk about some of its
applications it is used in popular iOS
apps like WordPress Mozilla Firefox
SoundCloud and even that annoying game
flappy bird number two javascript and
typescript now the approximate sadly for
someone in this role is 110 thousand US
dollars now let's talk about some of its
features alongside HTML and CSS
javascript is one of the three core
technologies so the world wide web
javascript is an object-oriented
computer programming language which is
commonly used to create interactive
effects inside web browsers typescript
is a superset of JavaScript and adds
optional static typing to the language
some of the companies that use these
technologies are Google uber Udacity
Microsoft and Accenture now let's talk
about some of the applications it is
used in the front end of several popular
websites like Google Wikipedia YouTube
Facebook and Amazon it is used in
popular web frameworks like angular JS
no J's and react.js
and in number one we have Python which
shouldn't come as much of a surprise to
you it is one of the most commonly used
languages around the world
now the approximate salary of a Python
developer is 115 thousand US dollars now
let's talk about some of its features
it's a great language for beginners
because of its readability and other
structural elements it makes things
easier to understand it's free
open-source and is widely used today
it's got extensive support modules with
community development user-friendly data
structures UI based desktop applications
can be easily develop using Python
there's easy integration into web
services and is a popular tool for
machine learning and deep learning some
of the companies that use this
technology are Facebook's Toyota
Citibank NASA and New York University
now let's talk about some of the
applications of Python it is using 2d
imaging and 3d animation packages like
blender in scape and Autodesk there are
games that are created using Python like
civilization for Vegas trike in toontown
there are scientific in computational
applications like free cat and abacus
and also popular websites like YouTube
Korra Pinterest and Instagram if you
feel like you want to learn something
new yet simply learn are here to help we
have courses in Python JavaScript Swift
Java C sharp scale of angular are no J's
and silly
you're just one click away from taking
your first step to get certified and get
ahead I hope you guys found this video
informative and helpful
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simple on hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here